BIG FAN OF BOTH OF YOU.
>> BIG FAN OF YOURS.
>> AND ARTIE, THE GUY, HE BARELY
HAS A JOB, AND I DON'T KNOW IF
THE INK IS DRY ON THE CONTRACT.
>> WELL, WELCOME TO THE MACHINE.
MY FAVORITE COMICS ARE
DANGEROUS, AND YOU DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
SAYING, AND THE GUYS THAT ARE
DANGEROUS.
AND THIS GUY LOOKS LIKE AN
UNDERWEAR MODEL, AND I AM GLAD
THAT HE IS ON THE EDGE, AND I'M
GLAD THAT HE DID SOMETHING EDGEY
AND CRAZY AND SOME OF THEM WERE
OLD.
AND ME AND JON WERE TALKING
ABOUT THEM, OLD.
>> AND YEAH, FROM HIGH SCHOOL.
>> AND THAT IS THE THING, AND
REMEMBER THE WHOLE THING WITH E!
AND SOMETIMES IT IS THE WHOLE
THING WHO SAYS IT.
BECAUSE IF JOEFR RIVERS SAYS IT,
FUNNY, AND IF JULIANA RANSIC
SAYS IT, OH, NO.
>> AND DON RICKLES THE SAME, AND
IF YOU READ IT ON PAPER, IT IS
MOST OFFENSIVE EVER.
BUT I DO SUPPORT TREVOR NOAH,
AND HE SHOULD GET THE JOB, AND
HE IS GOING TO GET OUT OF THE
K
CONTROVERSY, AND HE IS GOING TO
BE FIP.
>> AND THIS, MAYBE IT IS SOCIAL
MEDIA DRIVEN, AND I FIND NOW
THAT JOHN, PEOPLE ARE OUTRAGED
FOR THE SAKE OF BEING OUTRAGED.
>> RIGHT, THE NATIONAL ED ADDICN
IS UMBRAGE AND EVERYBODY LOVES
TO BE OFFENDED ON THE SOCIAL
MEDIA, AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT UNITE THE KONCONSERVATIVESD
PROGRESSIVES IS THAT WE WANT TO
BE BE OUTRAGED.
AND THEY WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN SO
MUCH IF HOWARD OR CARLIN HAD
SAID IT, IT WOULD HAVE BEEN HAVE
A PUNCHLINE, BUT NOT AS FUNNY
BECAUSE PEOPLE DON'T KNOW NOAH,
BUT PEOPLE ARE JUDGING THE WHOLE
CAREER BASED ON A FEW WHOLE
JOKE, AND IF THAT IS THE CASE,
EVERY COMEDIAN SHOULD GET THE
CHAIR.
>> AND YOU KNOW EVERYBODY OVER
THERE AT COMEDY CENTRAL, AND WHY
WOULD THEY CHOOSE HIM?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW WHY,
BECAUSE HE IS FUNNY, AND I WISH
HIM WELL TO BE SHOW, BUT PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW THE GRIND OF WHAT IT
TAKES TO DO A 10-HOUR SHOW, AND
YOU GET A HEADLINER CHRIS ROCK
WHO IS GOING TO GET THAT ROLE,
BUT CHRIS ROCK IS NOT GOING TO
TO GET A MOVIE TO GET 12 HOURS
TO GET, AND I WOULD HAVE LIKED
LOUIS BLACK, AND I KNOW THAT WE
HAVE THE OUTRAGE, BUT WE HAVE
THE ATTENTION SPAN OF THE GUY ON
MOMENTO.
>> AND FULL OUTRAGE, AND IT IS
AMAZING, BECAUSE YOU SAY
SOMETHING ABOUT SOMEONE OR TO
SOMEONE, AND THEY ARE NOT
OFFENDED, AND THEN YOU HAVE A
MACHINE.
>> THAT IS WHY IT IS HARD TO
OFFEND COMEDIANS.
>> THERE IS A WHOLE COMMUNITY,
AND JAMIE FOXX GOT IN TROUBLE
WITH THE TRANSOPERATIVE
COMMUNITY.
AND THE LAST COMMUNITY THAT YOU
CAN MAKE FUN OF ARE THE FAT
GUYS, AND NOBODY GETS OFFENDED
AT THAT.
>> WELL, SOME MUSLIMS MIGHT
DISAGREE WITH THAT.
>> AND SOME GUY CALLS ME OBESE
WITHERSPOON, AND SHOULD I GET
THE FAT COMMUNITY TOGETHER TO
PROTEST THIS GUY?
NO, BECAUSE I AM NOT OFFENDED.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT JAMIE FOXX
WAS OFFENDED?
I LAUGHED.
>> THE GUY WHO WON THE DECATHLON
IN 1976 IS BECOMING A BROAD.
IF YOU CAN'T LAUGH.
>> AND BRUCE JENNER IS A
TRANSGENDERED WOMAN, AND IF YOU
CAN'T UNDERSTAND THAT, IT IS A
STORY OF SURVIVAL.
AND JAMIE FOXX WAS NOT MAKING
FUN OF TRANSJGENDERED PEOPLE, AD
HE WAS PUTTING DOWN A CELEBRITY.
AND IF YOU WANT TO BE OFFENDED,
THEN FINE.
>> AND IN A WEIRD WAY IT IS
GOING TO BE QUITE NORMAL.
>> HAVE YOU EVER H HUNG OUT WITH
A TRANSGENDERED PERSON, BECAUSE
THEY MAKE FUN OF EACH OTHER ALL
OF THE TIME.
>> I DID SATURDAY NIGHT AND I'M
NOT KIDDING, DID.
>> AND YES.
THEY DO.
>> AND IF YOU CANNOT COMMENT ON
THE STORY, WHY NOT, AND ARE WE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO MAKE JOKES
ABOUT AIRPORTS?
>> OKAY.
BACK TO THE TREVOR, AND WE HAVE
GONE OFF TO JAMIE FOXX, AND I
WANT TO GO TO THAT HE WAS ON THE
SHOW, AND WATCH, HERE IS A CLIP
OF HIM ON THE SHOW.
>> SOME OF THE CLASSIEST RACISM
THAT I CAME ACROSS IN AMERICA
WAS IN LEXINGTON, KENTUCKY.
AND IT WAS CHARMING RACISM.
>> WELL, THEY PERFECTED IT DOWN
THERE.
>> AND HEY, THEY SAID THE MOST
AMAZING THINGS.
>> AND THE KU KLUX KLAN ARE IN
REAL SILK SHEETS DOWN THERE.
>> AND HE IS TALKING ABOUT RACE
THERE.
>> AND YES.
>> AND SHOULD PEOPLE HAVE SAID,
IN ARKANSAS?
SHOULD THEY HAVE -- KENTUCKY.
>> YES, MAKING FUN OF THE RACISM
IN KENTUCKY, AND HE IS TALK
ABOUT A FACT.
YOU KNOW, THAT IS WHAT IS COMICS
DO, AND YOU BRING UP THE
CONTROVERSIAL STUFF A LOT OF THE
TIME, AND A LOT OF US GET BORED
WITH THE TYPICAL SUBJECTS THAT
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO